did you know that Liv and Maddie almost
wasn't about twins at all and that Doug
Cameron played a character that wasn't
Liv or Maddie that's only the tip of the
iceberg when it comes to Disney shows
that were almost completely different
from the ones we know and love Hannah
Montana almost had a different name and
Cameron Boyce wasn't even supposed to be
in Jessi there's plenty more where those
came from so let's take a little trip
down memory lane and explore the
childhood we would have had if these
Disney shows hadn't gotten major
makeovers miss lane and I were actually
twins in this show our favorite show
about twins almost wasn't about twins at
all in the beginning it was called bits
and pieces and while it was still going
to start off Cameron she was supposed to
play a completely different character
named Alana
when Doug showed up on set for rehearsal
she found out that Alana was no more and
she was suddenly Liv and Maddie Disney
wanted to do something a little
different so the show was completely
reworked so it would include twins with
very opposite personalities you know to
spice things up a little but the role
change was actually terrifying for dub
it was kind of like a nervous wreck
because I did an audition to play the
twins really only auditioned to play one
person but it all worked out in the end
dov may have been scared but she also
thinks the challenge helps make her a
better actress and jumpstart her career
in a way that plane a single character
never would have and we can't help but
agree Liv and Maddie are iconic and Dov
was the perfect choice to bring the
blonde sisters to life I've decided to
stick with the number 5 that's the day
my best friend was born a fun fact about
Jessi is that Debbie Ryan wasn't just a
leading lady she also worked with the
producers to help create the show at
only 17 years old no one else could have
played Jessi because Debbie helps them
base the character off her own voice and
personality if they've taken the concept
for the show to a different actress
Jessi would have been totally different
another irreplaceable part of Jessie is
Cameron voice we were first introduced
to the late star when he played Luke
Ross and we couldn't imagine it any
other way
but before Cameron was cast Luke was
supposed to be named hero and he was
supposed to be Korean but then the
casting director saw Cameron and they
just had to have him in the show so Luke
was basically created just for Cameron
which makes us love the character even
more so you know how Disney just loves
to name their characters after Disney
Channel stars like how they based Miley
Stewart off of Miley Cyrus and Raven
Baxter off of Raven Symone well
producers almost did the exact same
thing with The Suite Life of Zack and
Cody
stars dylan and Cole Sprouse were such a
big part of developing the show that for
a while what I thought they would name
the characters after them
yeah actually our characters were based
off of Dylan and Colt but eventually the
idea was scrapped and we can see why The
Suite Life of Zack and Cody does have a
better ring to it than the suite life of
dylan and Cole but that's not the only
big change that would have made the
suite life totally different ashley
tisdale almost wasn't Maddie
instead the actress audition for the
role of london tipton the casting
directions ultimately decided she would
make an even better Mady which worked
out great for us because we can't even
imagine ashley and brenda song switching
roles still ashley has proved that she
can pull off the spoiled rich girl vibes
thanks to her time as Sharpay in High
School Musical and she technically did
get to play the spoiled rich girl in the
sweet life when she reprised her role as
Sharpay for the school musical but
she'll always be our maddie fitzpatrick
I'm so sorry London I wish I could do
something to help Sabrina carpenter and
Rowan Blanchard as Maya Hart and Riley
Matthews in Girl Meets World seemed like
the perfect casting choices but did you
know that their roles were almost
reversed that's right at first Sabrina
was Reilly and Rowan was Maya can you
imagine how different the show would
have been if the actresses had to
completely swap personalities that's not
the only major rework the show got Riley
was also supposed to have an
your brother named Elliott an actor teo
home was cast in the role that last
minute they decided that Girl Meets
World should be more about girl power
and that an older brother just wasn't
necessary
teo took to twitter to share the news
and while we love the show focusing on
two girls growing up we are kind of
curious about what Elliott would have
been like maybe he would have turned out
more like Cory's big brother Eric the
enemies not each other guys you're all
going through the same thing Wizards of
Waverly Place went through a lot of name
changes before they decided on the title
we all know and love it was originally
supposed to be called the amazing
Hannigan's then the amazing O'Malley's
and then simply Disney's Wizards
but once the Waverly placed substation
became a bigger part of the story it
made sense to go with something a bit
more original than just Wizards like the
earlier names suggests the Wizards
almost weren't Rousseau's at all Selena
Gomez was supposed to play Julia
O'Malley
before her name was changed to Alex
Russo and we like Alex way better
I'd agree that Alex Russo is officially
the Russo family wizard plus Alex and
Justin were originally supposed to be
twins Selena and David Henry look enough
alike that maybe they could pass her
fraternal twins but we like Justin being
an older brother a whole lot more there
were also a few stars that almost made
it into the show did you know that Joe
Jonas auditioned to play Justin Russo
and almost got the part Demi Lovato's
older sister Dallas was almost a part of
the show too
she was supposed to play a series
regular before her character got cut
after filming the pilot she did get to
appear briefly in one episode though
this season one episode Alex's Spring
Fling excuse me ken hi we're going out
like right now sindhya was a huge part
of casey undercover so much so that they
changed the show's name from super
awesome Katie because she didn't like it
the reason she got to have so much power
behind the scenes wasn't just because
she had already proven her star power
with shake it up it was because at only
18 she was already a producer on the
show
zendaya said invest in an interview with
vogue I got in a room with the heads of
Disney Channel and I was like the title
is whack that's got to change she also
inspired a few other changes in the show
and I came into this with like a strong
vision of what I wanted first she didn't
want her character to sing and dance
because that was all over the Disney
Channel already and she wanted her
audience to know that there are other
things that a girl can be instead
zendaya focused on making sure Kasey was
smart and really good at martial arts
zendaya also made sure she had an
all-black family and demanded more
diversity in the cast
basically Kasey is India's passion
project from when she was only a
teenager let us know in the comments if
you'd love to see her produce another
Disney Channel show one day honestly I
just wanted to do what I love to do and
I want to be happy we can't imagine a
world without Hannah Montana but the
Disney Channel was very close to giving
us a show about a teen pop star named
Alexis Texas yep that was the show's
original name and it only got changed
because it turned out that the name was
already taken what a relief
we almost didn't get Miley Cyrus in the
role either the Disney Channel
originally wanted teen pop star Jo Jo to
portray the secretive singer but she
turned it down then when Miley first
auditioned for the show she actually
auditioned for Lily Prescott showrunners
thought she was way too young to play
Lily or Hannah
but since the show took years to get
cast Miley was finally the right age by
the time filming started and the young
star was definitely made for the role
they named Miley Stewart after her and
even cast her dad Billy Ray Cyrus as her
on-screen father but this last change to
Hannah Montana is the one were the
happiest about did you know that at
first the whole show was supposed to end
with Miley finding out her life as
Hannah was a dream who are thankful they
didn't go with that idea since finding
out that Miley's dream life really was
just a dream would have made the whole
show a lot less inspiring I know that
this is a dream of ours but this is a
dream of mine too
Lizzie McGuire is a show about a girl
growing up and dealing with dating
friendships and sometimes fighting with
her family but did you know that at
first the whole show was supposed to
focus on Lizzie's relationship with her
mother oh and it was supposed to be
called what's Lizzie thinking we're
happy they decided to include all
parts of Lizzy's life or else we
wouldn't have gotten to see her obsess
over
Ethan Kraft sure I'm game goalie see you
tomorrow after school and spend most of
her time with BFFs Miranda and Gordo but
one aspect of the show that was never
going to be different was animated Lizzy
and thankfully she's also supposed to
come back for the show's reboot
well if Hilary Duff and the Disney
Channel ever agree on a direction for
the new show it's hard to imagine that
Raven Symone wasn't originally the lead
star on that So Raven but it's true
Raven actually auditioned for the role
of Chelsea at first but the casting
directors loved her so much that she
just had to be the star at first the
series was supposed to be called the
future is on me but once Disney cast
Raven in the main role they decided to
change the name completely who we're
happy Raven ended up becoming the star
because her ability to take on so many
different disguises as Raven Baxter
inspired the show's creativity Plus
Ravens singing voice made music a big
part of her character's personality
Raven also took the lead in getting the
spin-off series Ravens home picked up
and made by Disney austin and Ally
creators recently came clean about the
fact that Ally almost had a brother the
character eventually evolved into Dez
when they decided that Ally didn't
really need any siblings we wouldn't
trade Dez for anyone but it would be
kind of cool to see how Ally would get
along with an annoying sibling that kind
of turned into the desk actor but that's
not the only thing about Ally's family
the showrunners decided to change her
parents were supposed to happen part of
a super cool 80s band that only had one
big hit they decided to scrap that idea
and not feature the band on the show but
they made sure to include the sonic boom
record store to show her family's
connection to music but the odds of
making the music biz are like a
bazillion to one Jonas was almost a
completely different show with a bit
less focus on music in fact it was
supposed to be a show about spies Jo na
s originally stood for junior operatives
networking as
this show was supposed to follow the
Jonas Brothers as they attempt to
balance a band while working as secret
government agents sticking with music
but not the guys being spies made sure
the show played off their brother
strengths but the three of them have
refilled that they don't really like
Jonas that much and it probably delayed
their music careers because they were
always playing for the same audience
this show would have been crazy
different without all the music and high
school shenanigans but we would kind of
love to see the Jonas Brothers become
super spies dude we don't have time for
a song
do you wish any of these Disney Channel
shows had kept their original ideas let
us know your thoughts in the comments
don't forget to hit that like button and
subscribe to the things for more great
videos thanks for watching and we'll see
you next time